joining me now is Tom Holman former
acting ice director and a Fox News
contributor and former DNC comms
director and former communications
advisor to President Obama
Luis Miranda Thom besides the wall what
other legislative fixes must Congress do
well I think the two top ones is a TV PR
a trafficking Victims Protection Act
this is when unaccompanied children come
across the border the Central American
children are treated differently than
sit with children from Mexico Canada
once they find out they're not true
victims of trafficking if you're from
Mexico or Canada they can remove them
right away one from Central America they
get all these extra rights they end up
stay in the country for years going
through an immigration process that the
Mexican children the Canadian children
don't get so we need to fix that all the
children e2b have the same set of rules
and that will solve a lot of the UAC
crisis the other thing is unaccompanied
children
the second thing for top of those
numbers I mean number is kind of can be
sterile those numbers are staggering so
when these people on television umbers
have gone down from 2004 and they show
the chart we're all supposed to go ooh
the chart 63,000 people come in those
kids have to go to public school they
have to be cared for they often have are
on food stamps other public assistance
we got two blocks from here people
sleeping in the streets who have a sign
that say I'm an Air Force veteran
sleeping in the streets tonight that
makes a good points let's add the other
legislative our priority needs to take
place 160,000 family units now what we
need address there's a florist set of
agreement because a Ninth Circuit judge
ruled that we can't detain families for
more than twenty days now back in fy14
when we first started a family detention
we had these hearings within 40 45 days
and once we fill planes up above 90%
that lost your hearings the numbers went
down over the illegal crossings but some
judge Ninth Circuit says no you can't be
more in 20 days exactly I like which
means they get released and that's why
there's a surge of family members right
now for they know they won't be detained
they get released into the public many
don't show up in court and if they show
up in court and lose their case which 90
91 percent loser case less than 2
percent leaves that doesn't open borders
to Janice we need to address the flora
settlement agreement ok the Florence
Flores settlement agreement has to
really Louis it seems that just a few
years ago Democrats believed in border
walls I remember operation gatekeeper in
San Diego that was a Bill Clinton
initiative I covered it for CBS News in
1996 I was down there at the border like
wow operation gatekeeper huge barrier
steel barriers we're all for it let's
break this down with it what's changed
one of the issues here is that Donald
Trump is an expert at creating a crisis
like you know you deny that this is a
crisis at all I think that this is a
problem that we can deal with very
efficiently we have the resources we
have the people we have the ability to
face we don't have the people I honestly
want you to hate but we don't have the
manpower let me clarify this Trump just
as he did with North Korea as he does
with China he creates a crisis yes the
talk then compromises what in my angles
and I lay out Richard Haass Council on
formal Richard Haass yeah he's a big
supporter advice Richard Haass is in
favor of enforcing other people's
borders believe about safety immigration
peace okay so what in my angle did you
specifically disagree with what numbers
what what what one things to note is
that the Trump administration itself DHS
under Donald Trump in 2017 pointed out
that they are at some of the
historically lowest numbers of people
trying to cross the border now there
does seem to appear to be a surge in
October and November but we're not by
any means at a crisis level this is a
situation that yes we need to do more to
work with the three countries of
northern Central America Honduras
Nicaragua and El Salvador to make sure
that we're identifying ways to one
reduce the violence there
fight some of the criminal organizations
and perhaps work with them to establish
points where we can help with these
people so that they can request asylum
so 400 thousands like there I just have
to understand I know you are well
intentioned I know you I think you want
a solution to us I get it but how is it
not a bipartisan issue when 400,000
people come into our country illegally
every every year how is that I don't
care if it's down from 1.2 million from
five years ago that's bad too but
400,000 people they have to go to public
school they use our infrastructure they
get a range of money on border security
we have more than 16,000 Border Patrol
agents right now we have drones flying
and we have more than seven to pay for a
kid's college
high school-educated drones don't arrest
people look the same people are playing
birds and their crisis on the border
claim that wasn't a caravan and we found
out differently didn't we
there's a crisis on the border two
children have died and if Trump would if
we wasn't sued but ACLU and some Ninth
Circuit judge says no you can enter it
legally still claim asylum if they were
stuck with what President Trump wanted
come to the port of entry claim asylum
these two children belied sake they
wouldn't had a cross between the ports
of entry there's definitely an important
incentive to tell parents don't pay
smugglers don't work with these criminal
elements that are taking you through all
these countries to get to the southern
border that's fine we can all agree on
that
I didn't see any of the I see I don't
think any country in Central America
would want 400,000 people I mean I know
it's different cuz of smaller countries
they wouldn't want a big mass of people
coming into their countries who they
believed weren't invited or not welcomed
they no country wants a free flow of
humanity across the board I don't know
any country personally that wants them
the reason that this is yes right now is
because the wall is not necessarily the
right way to fix this because we already
have seven miles of fencing there's
definitely ways that we can impress you
keeper work in San Diego
I don't recall the specifics of it it's
we have we have a locking fence we have
a lot of there already we have it all
the way to El Paso and there's plenty of
other things that we need to do for
example detectors of seismic changes
because of the tunnels that they build
under now and those are the true
criminal down the government and have
five hundred thousand people not getting
paid to this point
a wall takes a long time how does that
address a crisis a Walt is not going to
be built overnight so how is that how's
that dealing with let's be clear i I was
at a meeting on the wild today I made it
clear one of the things he needs to talk
about is Walsh do work every place they
build a barrier illegal immigration
plummeted in San Diego Yuma El Paso so
he needs to put that false narrative
that Nancy Pelosi pushed off that walls
are ineffective there there there
medieval no the data proves that wall
works so let's get the American people
first of all work but we need to talk
about legislate let let us lay the
changes because families gonna keep
coming if they keep getting released
yeah
blacks from eight crisis that is not
worth shutting the government to well
it's the one can deal with increases in
immigration ways that we can deal with
the Central American problem you
basically when they come you want them
to stop trafficking I think that we
obviously have to allow someone who
wants to apply for asylum to apply for
it but there's ways they should stay
there's wait there's ways to deal with
these people even before they get to the
border without creating an unnecessary
crisis and shutting down the government
and having five hundred thousand
Americans who are not gonna get a
paycheck for over a month right they
they haven't not been paid they will be
paid when they okay since the twenty set
the Democrats don't want a border at all
isn't that the case you don't want a
border be paid at the 25th that's you
don't even question that kind of reveals
the lies I said very clearly that we
have always prioritized border security
by the way smartly not just building
Swiss cheese the media covers what
you're watching me to cover County but
you're gonna say that Trump ended this
crisis and it's just not worked on the
same sorry guys we're out of time all
right thanks you too